[Music]
and let it go news submitted by damn
mosquitoes good - right discusses what
we should do with all the stuff we own
that doesn't spark joy is this about
Marie Kondo yep it's Marie Kondo - the
match back joy
oh hell yeah schmuck joy hell yeah I'm
keeping this
spark joy yep
you can't say that to a hoarder yeah
everything sparks joy who's Marie Kondo
she invented that condominium she and
how do you guys see how do you guys seen
the Netflix I feel like I'm soul in the
dark lighting up with Marie Kondo and
then it's based on her book the like
magic magic of Talia I think this I
think the show kind of sucks
but I like her a lot I know such a corny
bad show dude I've never seen the show
but I read the book on puns on the show
I love the show because it's all [ __ ]
funny
did she go to hoarders houses yeah oh
there's a Japanese American house that's
[ __ ] disgusting yeah even the after
I'm like you could do this man there's a
lot of like hoarding behavior in
Japanese Americans I'm live we had a
friend that his grandma and grandpa did
but it comes from that broke farmer that
grew up here in a depression and they
can't let go of anything there's white
people from that era to that yeah but
she doesn't think okay she does this
thing where she's like she wants to give
blessings to the house before she starts
something right and it's it's it's
culturally Japanese but it's really
weird because I think sometimes
Americans are kind of too cool for a lot
of [ __ ] yeah
so then you see the awkwardness in the
weirdness in everyone's like vibes when
she wants to give thanks and kind of do
her little it's kinda like a little
blessing meditation we call it Concha or
and then before we do or before we do
martial arts do we do it it's called
Mook saw but then you just kind of like
you tune everything out before you start
a task yeah
and then you just close your eyes slate
yeah you can inch but she calls it
thinking the house so she looks like
she's worshiping the house and then so
you have all these like Christian
families that are like well that's so
weird because like you could just think
of it as being God and then they would
be so freaked out but like in her book
she talks about listening to the house
too so during the like part where she's
thinking the house she's like asked the
house to tell you what it needs to be
cleared out like what needs to what in
the house yeah that makes sense
I mean it's not weird to me but it's not
listen to you the watching the
interaction happen and you just have all
these like family is just like cuz
things don't transitive well you can
thank the house what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] crazy like what the [ __ ]
I think I'm translate well from like
Asian to like American [ __ ] either so
like that's the best way you could
describe it it's thank the house pray to
the house you know TV yeah yeah it's
like it's like being thankful and being
having gratitude - right it's my it's a
new concept here in the states but it
almost looks like she's going crazy and
worshiping some [ __ ] spirit she's
like thinking each item is if each if
you were truly thankful for each of your
items that you own then you would take
care of them and you would have a home
for each one of them and you would like
keep everything nice but since we live
in a culture that's all about consuming
and like buy more and more and more and
more and more you're not truly grateful
for each individual item that you have
so she has you go through and touch each
thing and really decide if that really
sparks joy or if it's just something
that you're like I think I could wear
that in a few years or like I think I
could wear that next year and like this
one would be [ __ ] dude his joy is
literally to buy dope [ __ ] I love don't
get to the house he would look into a
for he loves joy she's not against that
as long as you get rid of all the stuff
that doesn't have a lot of [ __ ] but I do
in a sense where like you try to have
your back no you have my back you have
my back a new one yeah yeah yeah
but for example again I already have one
Lamborghini of rifles oh my god I don't
need like three other Lamborghini of
rifles you know I just need one
Lamborghini of rifles one Lamborghini of
pistols but why do I have seven pistols
we're gonna sell them no that's true I
have to the same exact pistol see but
it's double double the dope Ness
yeah because I wanted to do twinsies but
if both of them sparked joy for you then
that's okay
it does that's okay [ __ ] like the
American mentality is like still sitting
in somewhere in my house see there's a
closet or the garage cuz I'm like I
might use that is it yeah but if the her
thing is like if you really were gonna
use it or if it really have done it
already
you would have done it already or you
could just buy one when that actually
happened I haven't read any of her stuff
but I've been kind of listening but
that's always kind of been my mindset
that one so it's like if I haven't used
it at this point I'm not gonna use it
that's what I do and when it comes to
like chords and all this other [ __ ] that
I like I would store in a drawer or
something I'm like okay if I don't know
what this is that means I haven't needed
it this whole [ __ ] yeah I'm throwing
that [ __ ] I had the worst habit of that
because I have so many [ __ ] chords so
I put it in bins Oh Steve she's very
organized with them I see that [ __ ] and
I go you know what I might need 12 USB
cords one day I don't know if I really
need it
I'll buy it and if I have a point I'm
[ __ ] that's why we don't have any
chomp oh my god Steve was like let's
live together no way and when he finds a
cord that we actually do need like he's
like oh I bet he uses it like what as an
excuse for keeping this entire box of
cords that we've never everything he was
born during the Holocaust
but it's a random stuff like that like
where it's like just courts and I'm like
okay at least like rap oh and make them
look nice no it's just a [ __ ] box I
have the veljko zip ties and I tie them
like that
you are very nice you never look for
stuff around the house and said Oh
where's that jacket it's so cold and
you're like oh just made me throw it
away
that never happened to you leave me no
no one makes me throw away smart though
when somebody went through a lot of [ __ ]
because you can't tell them so for
example Mike my cousin he married a
white girl she's polish and then they
went to their great grandma's place
right she's all this like horror like
everything I'm talking about like a
spool of string she has it somewhere and
it's just horde like hoarding to the
[ __ ] max yeah and then he had to go
over there and help her clean up [ __ ]
but she didn't want to throw anything
away so he got so [ __ ] fed up he got
a little you know a little angry he goes
feels like grandma do you really need
all this stuff you could throw this all
out like this is causing the family
stress and she goes well Jason during
the Holocaust he goes alright you win
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah she goes well you know when I was
in the Holocaust he goes you can keep
anything that's a trump card what do you
say that [ __ ] done yeah that's true I
don't have an excuse I'm just lazy it
feels so good though you get rid of like
it feels good when someone does it and
you walk in and it gives me anxiety if
someone else yes someone else says that
I don't like not having that you what
cleaning up my place I'm gonna clean it
out again now I could probably do it
three more times dude cuz right now I
have a rubber kendo sword [ __ ] I don't
know why I have it yeah so I think the
first time people do it they're not
completely honest like they they go like
they keep a lot of the stuff that's in
the neutral pile just alright yeah a
second time you go through it you're
like what was I thinking
yeah out if you're on the fence about
something probably does it's technically
you don't even need a mattress so what
is it that you do it I mean laughs you
just throw that [ __ ] I'll sleep on the
floor what do you what are you going to
do with everything you get rid of look I
donate it I think you understand
my clothes fit my friend confused she
just takes all of my old clothes and
she's done that since high school and we
were the same size so she just took all
my old clothes some of them had tags on
him which I felt bad about throwing away
but then in her book it's like don't
feel bad about throwing away new stuff
because it fulfilled its purpose already
the joy came from when you bought it
and now the joy is no longer there I
feel better and it'll find a new joy -
I'll take it that barbell Brigade stuff
does Kenny know what is this article
this article saying like what you can do
with the things that you already got rid
of the didn't spark joy for you so for
example for clothes we all know you can
donate it donate it to like Salvation
Army a goodwill or whatever but they're
just giving you other options that you
might not have thought about your
distress all right what does that yeah
it changes color it changes to different
color no I mean like the article the
article so it's saying um so for example
you can if you have like brand-name
things that are in good condition you
can sell it on sites like watch marker
thread up or you could go to Buffalo
exchange or like other consignment shops
and then you can you can get money for
the good stuff uh donate all my [ __ ] me
too
- all my photos all gone this article I
was reading it like this I don't work it
is a lot of work it's easier just to put
it in the bag and donate get it out of
your life for sure make a few hundred
bucks I understand but the amount of
work that it takes to do that you could
have made money somewhere else
or if you live in LA yeah just throw it
off the balcony and watch a bunch of
bums run up and catch it and run away
and then the [ __ ] bums are waiting
for it I love the Cleveland I give her
all my old clothes I go here you go cuz
she doesn't ace it to the church and the
church like Mexico and I like my closet
looking like a store yeah it looks
really good if I open the drawer and
it's just one ladle in there but your
store is like [ __ ] up no
no audience I know where hold on in my
cubicle in my cubicle on top of my
clothes it's one hat per box you are so
excited this blade for me it's all about
dope [ __ ] that's sparks joy it's gotta
be dope here and dope over there oh you
know that it's not gonna spark joy for
you later though cuz that's done that's
that's happened to me you buy it again
no it's old you can't buy the Seljuk
thing and you should have cherished that
when you first had it a lot of people
think that they're like oh I'm gonna
miss this item but rarely are there
items that you actually I've had that
problem that's why it's hard for me to
go like let it go because I have
experienced moments where I'm like [ __ ]
where's that one thing that I had what
it is give you a better version tell me
what it was so the one that popped in my
head first was this Teletubby not so
it's it was it called the beanie babies
purple beanie baby that I got when I was
seven right after she died Princess
Diana version of it and then I found out
that now it's worth a lot of money so I
was looking everywhere for that's why
I'm new reason to I couldn't find it
anywhere so you win the lottery with
fifty million dollars that's gonna make
even more it didn't happen yeah but you
did win the lottery you met Casey and
you're a beautiful girl we both won the
lottery okay there it is there it is so
don't worry about the beanie baby okay
yeah so that's like one of the things
she but that never happens with a shirt
it just doesn't that's true yeah I'm
gonna throw away all my cords thank God
Vince need to do it please
well I can't I can't even convince him
to save his [ __ ] kid what do you
think I'm gonna do with electrical cords
well drink water just drinks diet so
don't know what sparks joy is when I
watched somebody fold my clothes you're
interested in the other four sections of
Marie condos thing cuz you know it's
like clothes books paper yeah come on no
which is miscellaneous and then
sentimental value things send that [ __ ]
to me critical has a whole bunch of
things that you can do but like I said
it's a lot of work what I like is it's
not about organizing a lot of like
places
focus on the getting more bins to
organize all your [ __ ] this is about
like getting rid of all like
decluttering only keeping positive
energy in your house that's what I
wasn't a fan of the show because I like
plan I need that too but I really was
excited to see how she organized things
and I didn't see that in this she's
suggest using like old shoe boxes and
stuff like that but I don't like throw
it out because it don't look like a
store
exactly gotta be so first I get rid of
everything and then you go on Amazon and
they are organizers for behavioral
problem to hoarding and to this
organization and all that and then she's
like it's because you guys don't have a
system and the reason why you don't have
a system is you don't know how to let go
of [ __ ] yeah that is true she also
doesn't really like hanging clothes she
needs you to fold them her method it
doesn't get wrinkled supposedly but it
does well if you got a astronaut suit
how are you gonna fold that my doll I
wouldn't know not the hanger it makes
sense though because her system comes
from the Japanese house and it's too
small everything's too small so they
can't like use big space I'm shaking my
life starting today I'm throwing people
in the garbage can
[Music]